[Applaudissements]
défi du jour à oued raisonnables où je
suis déjà en rayon la folie qu'un viens
là que j'te pousse africa africain
african je crois qu'il va le faire tout
de suite en fait j'allais vous voulez
faire maintenant jdo kg et on se donnera
blues mais j'ai trop s'il monte en plus
j oui oui c'est cyril c'est chaud là
[Musique]
bordel que je te couches sarsgaard
j'te dis
tous regardent à moi saga africa
l'africain j'ai pas bien compris la
vanne à là ça va bien ça va ça va un peu
oui
la série de services que l'on m'a
toujours dit que aprikian ça voulait
dire africains
ben voilà à pékin à la merci j le gros
flop j'ai gardé un petit dernier pour un
gars africa
[Applaudissements]